[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the second
episode of the agar matar podcast
yes we are still using that name and our
second guest is
none other than hikaru nakamura hello
hikaru how are you
uh hey antonio it's good to be on the
show i've watched a lot of your videos
been a fan for a while so it's good to
be here
uh thanks thanks a lot man uh we're very
glad to hear that uh and for those of
you who are maybe also
they're also new to the chess players uh
hikaru is uh
currently uh rated in the top 20 in
classical chess you are
number four in rapid chess and also you
are the only player in the world
currently uh ranked 2900 in over the
board chess
uh you are number one player in in blitz
so that's some uh three rating points
above uh above magnus
currently second and uh something uh
a lot of people would be interested in
is uh well how how
how you started your journey i mean
you've addressed this question quite a
lot but uh
before we get to that i would just like
to congratulate you on your victory
against dubov
uh to remain in the chesapeake masters
that was a quite
defeat uh what happened actually in that
game did you do
just overlooked that the the rook was
defending the bishop or
um i i have a feeling that basically
dubois thought his position was already
really bad around this time that i
played pawn to f6
um so i i think he must have seen queen
before rook f2 but i think he felt that
even if he had played um
this line with knight f6 e5 94 uh he
would have been much worse in the game
so he decided to take a gamble and just
just go away
yeah but i i also have a feeling that he
was not completely aware of the
situation
either and that by losing that game he
won't qualify everyone that he thought
he was going to qualify no matter what
happened in that game
so i think it was a combination of sort
of not feeling happy with this position
but also not realizing that if he lost
that game he won't qualify so i think it
was a mix of those two factors
okay uh well all in all very very glad
that you were able to remain
in the competition and now regarding uh
how
everything started basically you were uh
the the
youngest ever player to defeat an
international master you were the
youngest ever to defeat a grandmaster
you were the youngest the international
master
so you were i mean you definitely could
be considered a prodigy
now a lot of people are asking me this
and i always get a lot of questions from
subscribers when preparing for a podcast
how how did it all started start and how
did you
get such well such a clean uh
upward uh well progress right so i mean
i i've said this many times basically uh
my origins and chess
started um around the time that i was
six and seven years old so
i was born in japan uh to an american
mother who who studied in japan for for
nine years and lived there for or
studied for like four years to study
abroad at college and i ended up moving
there
marrying my biological father and then
my brother and i were born in japan but
my mom
and my my father they separated in uh
at the end of 1989 so when i was about
two years old my mom moved back to
california with my
my brother and i um and then i think
when my brother was about like
maybe five years old i would say five or
six i i obviously don't remember this um
because i was way too
too little but my brother started taking
lessons um with this group called chest
for juniors it was i think based and
based
in and around the la area and so my
brother became very good at chess he he
was improving very quickly i think
um from the time he started he had a
very quick ascent from basically zero to
i want to say maybe it was like 17 or
1800 very very quickly so he kept
improving really fast and
um when when he started competing in
these national tournaments
around the country with other kids in
his age group my mother met my
stepfather snow where montre who was a
very prominent chess coach
mainly known for coaching at hunter
elementary school
and uh and so they met through that they
got married at the end of 1993 actually
at a chess tournament um
in las vegas and then then we all end up
moving to new york and so
because my brother was already a very
strong chess player and my stepfather is
a feeding master as well
uh they were they were competing in
tournaments and chess was just all
around me and so by virtue of being
around chess all the time when i was
that little i naturally got interested
in the game
and it was specifically at the i believe
it's in 1994
united states chess open in concord
california
um when my brother and my stepfather
were playing you know their law class of
games on i think was one in one of the
evening rounds
um i went into the skittles room which
is basically
where where you analyze game skittles i
think that's an american term but anyway
you go to where people
analyze games and there was there was
this very nice guy i think he was also a
feeding master his name was
oscar tan i think he's i think he's
still around um
and i i went in there not knowing
anything i just want to play some games
and and he was
and an oscar was very nice he decided to
uh just play me and he actually lost a
couple of the games against it which
of course i mean he never he never would
have done normally but
but because i had that experience that
was sort of the first time that i got
into it and then um
and then i think was probably a few
months later i played my first couple of
tournaments back on the east coast
in in new york and i did very poorly in
fact
so um i played played probably i would
say maybe five or six tournaments i
i think people can go back and check the
actual record to see
but i played in a bunch of tournaments i
did not do very well i
had bad results i had a bad temper um
and so my parents aft
after a couple of months they decided
that it was best if i did not play chess
simply because my brother was already a
very promising junior player
my stepfather obviously had played was
was playing professionally
not professionally but he was playing a
lot of tournaments as well so
so because of that uh they decide that i
shouldn't play so i didn't play any
chess for probably about six months
and then then when i came back the first
one i ever played
uh after returning i i won my first
three games
pretty easily and then the fourth game
which is the last game of the event
i lost the form of checkmate um
so certainly uh you know it it's not a
storybook
storybook ending or anything by any
stretch but i i came back i started
playing them from there my improvement
was very fast i think having that break
having time not playing the game
something just clicked and and so i
started playing tournaments all the time
and then
really the big jump for me was when i
was about
i would say eight and a half or just
before i turned nine
uh i i don't remember how it was but i
had a random copy of the guinness book
of world records and in that book
um they they listed the youngest
youngest master
um and this was i think america it
wasn't the world at that time but
uh the youngest master record was held
by evie naibat who who actually i think
did
i don't know if he became a grand master
but he was at least an international
master
and he held this record so i saw it in
the guinness book of world records and
then i spoke to my stepfather and
we kind of thought well it's fun you're
improving very quickly why not take a
shot at it
and um and so during that one year
period between nine and ten i basically
played
i think i played about i don't remember
the exact number someone can obviously
fact check this later but it was
something like i played 930 games during
that one year span and my rating went
from about 1700
to 2200 when i became the youngest
youngest master
in american history so that i think was
really the big big moment that it all
sort of clicked and obviously i could go
on and on but that was sort of when i
knew that i was gonna
that i was gonna have a promising career
or at least i was gonna
probably get to like international
master of grand master and
at what point did you feel like you
could already maybe
maybe battle it out with with the top
guys
right so i i think um
probably the first time that i really
felt that that i could compete with
top guys maybe not the absolute top of
the top was there there was this uh
well i can go into the story but it was
2000 it was 2007.
um so basically in 2006 i i stopped
stopped playing chess i decided i was
going to go to college for a little bit
i did enjoy it i dropped out this is
something we could talk about
as well later potentially but i dropped
out of college and i was sort of just
like
just going along and just trying to play
chess in 2007 is when i really got the
big break because i played
played this tournament in um in
barcelona i believe it was it was called
this
barcelona casino tournament i actually
won this tournament
it had uh it had lenie dominguez and and
mostly like
these like 25 50 2600 spanish grand mass
and when i won this tournament
um somewhere in the middle of this event
uh a friend of mine mentioned that there
was there was this tournament in corsica
shortly after after this tournament in
spain i think it's
part of the course can course can
circuit and so
my mom and i decided to change our plane
tickets after this tournament in spain
and we went to corusca
and i played in um i forgot what exactly
it's called this tournament organized by
leo batesi the
very famous french and corsican
organizer and it was a rapid event
which i also won but during that during
that tournament i think i beat
i think i beat karpov there um i beat
van whaler but i also beat rustom
casting genre but i think
that was the first time that i really
felt that i could compete against
against players who were near the top
now sure you could say carp over casting
john these sorts of guys they weren't
at the very top but they were certainly
um people who were very prominent and
people who have long careers so
um that that i think is the first time
that i really felt it was it was
within the realm of possibility and then
i think um in terms of actually knowing
was probably when i played um my first
super term it's the tal memorial which i
believe was the um
that would have been i think the end of
2009 if i'm not mistaken i could be off
by one year but i think it was the end
of 2009
uh where i had this very famous uh last
round game
against alexander grisschuck uh which
which i did not win
um but it was it was around that time
when i went plus one in the in the town
memorial that i really knew that that i
was gonna
i was gonna get invitations and playing
talk tournaments with these guys
and then uh you were constantly getting
invited and
all of a sudden like a few years later
you're an elite player
yeah so i mean the progression i think
is so um
so 2000 so in terms of becoming an elite
player in 2009 i think that's the first
time that i broke 2700 i played in the
french
league i think in may i went over 2700
and then i played the us championship
right after that i did win the us
championship that was my second title
um and from there i played this
tournament in san sebastian which
which i won on top of that and i would
say that 2009 2010 when i broke in
was when i knew that i was going to be
there and then then in 2010 i
consolidated i started having good
results and
i broke into the top 10 and i mean from
there i
i think probably it was at least five
years until i dropped out of the top ten
again
or maybe it wasn't five years maybe i
briefly dropped out in 2012 but
uh for the next like next five years i
was more or less in the top ten pretty
consistently
but going through throughout all of this
progress to
from like a beginner to an elite player
uh did you always uh
enjoy certain time form it's more like
were you just
it was normal for you to play classical
or did you enjoy like rapid and blitz
more
yeah so i think i think i've kind of
come full circle i would say when i was
very young
this period between the ages of nine and
probably
nine and about twelve i really like
blitz i would say my biggest improvement
came from playing blitz games on the
internet chess club specifically
um so i really did get used to playing
blitz rapid chess i would say is not
something
honestly that i really became that
familiar with until probably
probably until like 2007 or 2008 because
mainly for me it was playing classical
chess or playing
playing blitz chess um or kind of like i
guess slower rapid chess like games
game 30 or game game 60 time controls um
as well but for the most part it was
blitz and then and then sort of
classical
after that but but blitz was definitely
my my main main thing for for a very
long time
well you mentioned the icc uh i i've
seen that you played it there under the
nickname capilano bridge
is there some story behind it did you
like really enjoy it and then you just
wanted to crush everyone with that
nickname or
yeah so i mean capilano bridge actually
is probably not the username i'm most
famous for um i think the two usernames
that people will remember the most are
um
when i was real really young and i
remember this was probably when i was
the
master and then i got video master was
the username year of the rabbit that was
that was actually the first username
that i became established with that i
think people saw
um i think i i don't know if there still
are the websites that list the highest
ratings but i know that you're the
rabbit was on some of those lists for
for a very long time then after you're
the rabbit um
the the username that i that i had which
i'm i'm most
commonly associated with was smallville
um
and there are stories to all these
usernames i mean you're the rabbit was
because i was born in 1987 and for the
chinese
the chinese calendar that that is the
year of the rabbit
um as far as smallville smallville was a
tv show that i really liked so
i used that one probably from about 2000
and i want to say 2005 maybe or 2006
until 2011 i believe it was and then
after that i used um
uh capilano bridge primarily and the
reason behind capilano bridge is
uh this also kind of falls on with the
whole
whole like timing but uh so so after i
after i
um after i dropped out of school and
i just i decided that i was going to
play chess i also kind of wanted to
to get away and do something different
and um in 2008 this
this is already after i've gotten around
2700 or close to in 2007
but when i was in the high 2600s like
2680s i think it was
in 2008 i decided that i wanted to just
go somewhere completely new
start off fresh and so i ended up going
to uh vancouver british columbia
and uh the capilano bridge it's a
suspension bridge
it's it's outside of vancouver probably
about an hour hour north
north of vancouver um on the north shore
but basically i went to vancouver and i
really
i really liked the landmark and so i
decided to make that my username i could
have picked many other
other landmarks but that's that's the
one that i use and even even to this day
um i would say that a lot of a lot of uh
the growth that i had in terms of as a
chess player and as a person
i would attribute a tribute to that time
period because it gave me i think
a much much better perspective on both
of the world but then also
of sort of the work that you need to put
in to to keep
making those slight adjustments in that
slight improvement because once you get
past about
i would say 2600 the improvement that
you have in chess generally
it's going to be very slight it's going
to be small as small things that you do
differently so
um so i always will be very fond both of
the city but also
the username as well uh okay uh so with
uh so much
blitz and rapid games being played every
day in the world
uh do you think uh classical chess will
like
sort of regain its former glory when
well this global log down uh ends
yeah so i mean i think uh first of all
in terms of streaming yeah i try i tend
to stream
every day um that's that's a much bigger
topic separate of this question uh but i
have streamed
uh for i think more or less last two to
two and a half
half months pretty much with just a day
off here and there um
now in terms of uh in terms of classical
just for a long time i've felt that it's
it's a dying format i think
when you look at almost any any sort of
sport in the world now obviously there
are a lot of viewers who are not from
north but not from north america but i
i'll use baseball as a good example
because it's probably the it's one of
the oldest american sports and one of
the ones that
it's it was at least considered
america's pastime
and what has happened is in probably the
last like i would say 15 to 20 years has
other sports have surpassed it um
football and basketball being the
primary examples but i think even even a
sport like tennis is probably
uh washed a lot more than baseball these
days the reason for that is because when
you look at baseball
it's a very slow game the game takes
three hours or very few moments where
something really exciting is happening
and in many ways i feel that chess is
the same
so when you have these very long games
that are going six or seven
hours uh people only tune in for periods
they tune in at the start because the
exciting
the exciting part is the opening and
then they tune in like maybe four hours
because somebody gets low on time and
then if it's still going they tune in
um say late in the end game around the
sixth hour when both players are low on
time and it's get it's getting tricky
for one side
so uh to me i think classical chess
there's always going to be a place for
it but i think in terms of trying to
adapt
and and bring it to a bigger audience i
do feel that that rapid shots and blitz
chess
are the future and um and we're already
seeing it i mean you're seeing less and
less classical tournaments you're seeing
the grand chester for example
i know this this year there was going to
be two classical events but
previous two years i think it was like i
think it was one one event if i'm not
mistaken and
one classical event and three rapid
events so to me i think the future isn't
wrapped but i think people
want to watch game clearly with what
you're seeing on the internet the the
amount of interest
uh when if you have the right time
formats uh people will watch the game
and so
i i do think for something like the
candidates and the world championship it
always should be classical chess
but i do think going forward um we are
having more and more rap
chess events i think it's only going to
continue down that path and i think
that's
it's better that way especially
considering the uh
the advancement technology because when
you look at chess um
and this is sort of a philosophical
point but i've always felt that one
thing that i've really loved is when you
get to a position like it move 10 or
something
and both players are on their own it's
not something they prepare they're kind
of it's it's you against your opponent
and whoever whoever comes up with a
better idea and the better moves wins
the game and i feel that um
uh well actually just a side note this
is one of the things that i really loved
about my games against the former world
champion vladimir kramnik actually is
that
i felt that when we played a lot of our
games relatively early on we get to
these positions where both players were
sort of on their own
and trying to come up with with ideas
and the best moves and
and nowadays it feels like chess more
and more it's about the preparation so
you try to surprise your opponent
but it's usually much deeper in the game
so like the sort of the natural feel or
the natural intuition
is kind of getting drowned out by
technology and
and the computer engines so that's why i
also feel like with classical chess
in the past you needed that extra time
to come up with the best moves but now
when you play
because of computers you're already
getting to move 15 or move 20
um without without having to think at
all so having all this extra time to me
it doesn't actually make sense and it
sort of runs contrary to the way that
i've always always thought about chess
um so i i think classical chess will
exist but i don't think
um i i i don't think you're gonna see it
become more popular i think it's only
gonna you're gonna see less and less of
it
outside of the tournaments um that are
say qualifiers for the world
championship match
yeah uh okay but uh regarding yourself
will you
yourself be interested in uh for example
playing other tournaments in classical
time format other than maybe the world
chess championship cycle if you
if you if you still have ambitions for
that yeah
i guess what i would say is as far as
i'm concerned um when i look at
classical chess tournaments i do
think i will play in the u.s chess
championship
for the near foreseeable future i don't
know um when it will happen whether it
will even happen this year or not but i
do think that's one classical chess
tournament
that that i will be uh that i will be
we'll be looking to play going forward
um but in general yeah i mean
it doesn't even feel like there's that
many there are that many chess
tournaments honestly like
when i look at the classical tournaments
the only ones i can think of are like uh
gibraltar which is the big open there is
um there's granka although that's invite
only
um but already i feel like once you get
past those two events if you if you
don't if you don't think about the grand
chess tour already there
aren't that many uh many chess events
for for the top level players
anyway so yeah um i certainly i
certainly
will will play more classical
tournaments down the road but again
uh i already see more and more rapid
tournaments i think things like the
world blitz and rapid or even like these
grand chester events to me
i find them more appealing honestly i do
at this point and it's not that i don't
have ambitions
but i just feel like the the game is is
moving in a different direction
okay and uh i'm also interested in now
that
well your schedule is pretty much filled
up i believe with
uh all the streaming and collaborations
and uh
well just playing elite level uh
chess uh on pretty much on on a daily
basis uh do you still have time
to study chess yeah so i mean i do
i do a little bit of studying say like
probably an hour or two every day
um especially right before the events
which have been which have been going on
the lindoris abbey tournament as well as
this uh
as well as the shuttle master so i do i
do spend a little bit
of time studying but that's the other
thing i would argue which really appeals
to me
in general with rapid chess instead of
classical chess classical chess
is is very much about treating chess
like like uh like a mathematical
equation you're trying to find the
perfect solution
um and to me that's just not how i think
about chats i don't
feel that chess in its natural form is
like that like being able to use the
computer and find the perfect solution
runs counter to how i grew up playing
chess so i don't really like that
that approach in general which probably
is why i'm not a big fan of classical at
this point whereas with rapid chess
you still study you still have to be
very precise with your move orders and
finding the best opening setups um which
is
something i did not do against magnus
the other day yeah um
but but but generally like you you try
to find you still try to find the best
side so there's a lot of the intuition
the intuition and trying to find the
best move
when you're on the spot when you when
you're under pressure and to me that's
that's how should be it should not be
something where it's about
a math problem and finding the absolute
perfect setup which i feel is what
classical chess is in many ways turned
into so
uh my whole philosophy that's just based
on my philosophy of growing up with just
the way i did
uh that that's a big part of why i don't
um why i
just i i don't think classical chess um
is is gonna
be around forever and also the other
thing i would add as well just from a
pure statistical standpoint
is when you look at rapid games there's
a much higher decisive uh you have many
more decisive results
in classical chess the draw rate is
extremely high these days i think it's
somewhere around 70 percent
um if not higher for certain events like
i think the event in st louis even was
um the sink filled cup i think up until
maybe the
second to last round i think the draw
rate was something insane like it was
probably like 85 to 90 percent
and again with something like chess
where it's it's so popular
when you're trying to get it out there
you really need you really you need
sponsor you need people watching it when
you have
so many draws um it's just not something
that i think many people
can relate to they're gonna be
interested in frankly uh because the
only sport in the world where i think
you have that is
is soccer that's the only sport i can
think of where you have uh where you
have
you have draws you have ties um so so
yeah i
i i don't know what the future is going
forward but i think
i think in in general um you are gonna
see more and more of the quicker trust
yeah and even if there are many games
drawn in rapid and blitz chess it's
still much more exciting and you get a
next game much much more sooner right
and that's that
i mean i think there are many reasons i
see it that way so i think from like an
organ
organizational standpoint one thing that
a lot of people do not
are not familiar with is how expensive
it is to put on an elite chess
tournament so
when you look at like a grand chester
event you're talking generally about a
price but i would guess
probably a quarter of a million maybe
250 000 us dollars if not more but then
you have all the other
operational expenses like putting up the
players at hotels covering airfare
usually giving a stipend for food like
there there are all these other expenses
that also add up when you when you look
at a classical chess term which can go
say two weeks uh i mean every day every
day
every day counts and when you look at
rap tournaments uh of course it's a lot
less time you get more action because
it's not one game a day you can have
like three or four games every day
and so to me i just i think when you
look at the general structure of
everything it
rapid just makes a lot more sense for
chess players for organizers
and for the fans as well and i think i
think that's the main reason that i that
i
also fundamentally believe that rapid
chess is the future of the game
and uh uh how do you study when you
study how do you study openings
something i'm very interested in like do
you just
repeat the line until you have it
memorized until it's basically like
muscle memory or do you
is there like a certain uh
so i would say it's a mix of a couple
things i think if if it's during it
like an over the board tournament let's
we start there and then talk about the
online ones i think certainly
um it is very much about that because
when you play an online term at least
for me all the preparation i do
usually is before the event so uh since
most of the time you know your opponents
and the colors you're gonna have
a week or two in advance i'll try to do
all my preparation look for ideas
um and and come up with something that
that i'm familiar with
before the event and then write like the
day before then it's just
just like repeating it over and over and
over again to make sure you have it down
but generally it's just trying to think
about it from a
from a general standpoint of what
everyone is doing where people think
their
our ideas and where the holes are in
someone's repertoire um
and so normally it's more of that as
opposed to pure repeating until
until you feel like you have the whole
whole idea down
um like you feel like there are no holes
there's nothing more you need to look at
and that's when you start
start just doing the pure memorization
but generally um i found that pure
memorization
is is not a great tool to use unless you
do it
um right before a game because what
happens is then you don't really
understand
why the computer says play this move or
play that move
um so for so for the most part i i think
it's it's it's not a good thing because
then also when you only do that you
can't remember the reason
you do have certain situations where
you'll make a blunder um
like case and point my game against
wesley so from uh from the granchester
event in london i think it was
three years ago now where i where i
played white and grunfeld and i made a
blunder i think it was on move
moved nine or moved ten and um and that
was a direct result of uh
of like trying to memorize things so i
think you have to be very careful but
normally
i think it's trying to trying to see
what the other players are doing looking
for certain ideas
um as opposed to just like just like
repeating stuff over and over again
because again
when you're looking at top level
tournaments if you have an idea it's
only good for one game
that's that's all it works for and
that's what makes it so
challenging in many ways is that every
game uh is so critical and so important
and
and the ideas only exist for one game
like i could literally spend
you know i could spend the next week
looking at some idea and
well let's just stay in the berlin but
it's probably only going to be good for
one game okay and then i'm gonna have to
move on
so so generally it's just looking more
ideas instead of trying to repeat and
memorize completely because if you do
that
for something that's only going to work
for one game i think it's just
it's not the most efficient use of time
okay
and then when such a such a gem is
played
in a classical game everyone immediately
knows about it
and it will never work again right and i
think that's that's
that's one of the things to me that uh
looking at the generational shift is is
amazing about somebody like
like anon is so all the all of us who
are relatively young or we've only been
in chess
probably for the last decade decade and
a half um
our perspective is that if that's that's
normal you have this idea and if it
works it works and
and great but you don't really expect
somebody to to
to work for for longer than that and and
one thing that i find amazing is like
somebody like anand who actually was
playing against kasparov he was playing
in the mid 90s when
you could still you could play something
it would work for multiple games uh the
fact that
someone like that has been someone like
vichy has been able to um
sort of transform himself and like
accept them accept that
the new new reality mindset uh is
is is amazing to me because for all of
us who are younger we're used to it but
someone like vichy who
could play like the play the open
spanish or play i think he played the
open spanish
um how many games did he do that did you
like two or three in that match 95 i
think it was
um but but you would see like nowadays
the line that he played in in that
fateful tenth game which he lost
um uh where gary gary played the the tal
the towel line with knight shoot five um
like if
you look at something like that now that
would be fine for one game in a world
championship match that would not hold
up past one game
um so so it's really amazing to see see
the generational shift and also to see
some of these players like fishy where
they can do it because i know
from my own personal experience gary has
always had um had
issues accepting that uh it's not
something that he completely
completely gets okay uh bataan is pretty
much
the only one still still yeah i mean
i would say in such a top level i would
say that because like
somebody like boris and chooky they're
uh
yvonne they're both very strong chess
players even now
but i wouldn't say that they were still
capable of winning games and playing
and playing against the top guys on an
even playing field
um you know in the la last couple years
probably like five six years ago they
they
were but i would say it's been a while
whereas vishy still is
is competing at the at the top level
yeah and on a plane even playing for
all of us okay vasily would now be more
of a landmine like you
he could he could obliterate you but he
will probably not have a steady result
right and also what like with uh with
vasily i would say is that his his
repertoire
it's more about variety playing
everything and having a broad base of
knowledge instead of
instead of trying to trying to zone in
on one little one little line or one
little idea
um in the way that the vicious capable
of doing so it's also the playing style
is quite different
okay uh so regarding online chess now
that we have this like super big boom
and everything and it's like chess is
experiencing its uh well
maybe second or third renaissance uh
since it was invented
uh what would you attribute it to mostly
like not just mostly but
why why are we seeing this now
um so i mean i think there are many
reasons obviously the first and foremost
is with what's going on in the world
with covid um and people being stuck at
home
uh you're seeing you're seeing a boom in
in many many sort of i would say esports
and
online games uh besides chess as well
but i think the main reason chess is
saying this
is is because when you when you look at
when you look at the game of chess
there are very low barriers to entry so
whether this is online or over the board
it really really doesn't matter i'll
just use over the board
specifically but but if you look at
over-the-board shots what do you need to
play chess you basically you need you
need a chess board you can buy
i mean you can buy a basic wooden chest
set for probably like five or ten
dollars
uh it's not very expensive now getting
lessons in the rest of course there are
expenses but when you look at something
like i don't know like tennis even for
example or you look at
i guess golf is probably too too upscale
but if you look at tennis i know i know
because i took
i took tennis lessons when i was young
like um for tennis even buying buying a
good racket usually like one of these
good wilson rackets or
head which uh whichever brand it is
right there it's already probably 150
dollars to buy
to buy a good tennis racket just just to
play um
and so because of a very low barrier to
entry which this is all
i mean like i'm talking over but even
online it's the same thing because you
can literally just go online
and and create a free account on any
number of chess sites
you can just get going without needing
there is the cost isn't there
so uh that's the main reason that i
think chess has has
sort of that's that's the starting point
um beyond that i think
i think a lot has to do with the uh the
promotion i think certainly
what i've been doing on on twitch
specifically and other streamers
other chess rumors as well it hasn't
just been me um
is trying to find a way to bridge the
gap and bring it to people who are not
uh strong chess players i think one
thing that we
that gets missed very often in chess is
that
chess is a game where it's pure pure
skill there's very little luck involved
i mean there there is luck at the top
like you know someone plays this opening
or that opening
but it's very minuscule and so um very
often what i think
players and chess forget is that yes how
good you become a chess is a direct
result
of how much time and work you put into
the game but at the same time
just because you put in that that time
and work it doesn't necessarily mean
that in some way i'm better than you
or you know other people can't enjoy the
game and
and so to me i think that the biggest
thing is always finding a way to bridge
that gap because
the majority of chess players i would
say i i don't know is for a fact but i'm
guessing the majority of chess players
in the world are probably somewhere
between
1 000 rating and 1 500 is my guess and
so if you think
if you try to put that in perspective if
you want to grow the game or you want
more people interested in the game of
chess
that is the audience that you really
need to bring it to because that's where
the most chess players are um and so i
think that the fact that myself
people like alexandra botez um and
i mean they're they're people like
daniel naraditsky and many others um
eric rosen as well uh we're doing all
these collaborations and trying to
to to sort of relay it in a way that uh
people can understand
is very important because at the end of
the day you really do want the game to
grow it's not
you know i to me um as far as chess goes
like you know if i got hit by a bus
tomorrow
which i mean i i know is is not like
it's less likely than like uh winning
the water or something like that but
uh but you know like if i were to get
hit by a bust tomorrow i think i think
at the end of the day
what what you want to do is you want to
do something that leaves chest in a
better place and so for me
uh this is sort of been my attitude for
a long time is that yes i will have
these great games games like the game
against boris or the game
boris gelfand or the game against uh uh
krasankov
uh or bellayovsky these these amazing
like king
kings indian games they're gonna last
regardless of of
everything else but you still want to
try and do something to
to grow the game and as someone who's
spent
a lot of time um in the chess world
obviously the stepfather who's who's
coached for the last 40 years
um you know i've seen i've seen a lot of
a lot of enthusiasm at
many different points for the game of
chess um but
it seems to always die down it doesn't
if to me it doesn't feel like it ever
becomes as big as it should so i've
always had this attitude that
uh there has to be some way to try and
try and grow the game to make it more
popular and so what i've been doing on
twitch just these collaborations
what happened with pogchamps um it's my
way of trying to sort of give back and
grow the game
in a way that i think that in a way that
i think i can and i think it's been very
successful certainly i had no idea that
it would
that would turn into what it's what it's
turned into but
um i think mainly it's just trying to
bring it to an audience and and make
them feel comfortable in a way they can
understand
i think also back to you as well i mean
it's it's the same thing
what what you're doing with your
analysis in the games it's not so much
about catering to the top players i mean
they they will understand your videos
but it's about bringing it to the people
who are are going to um who are going to
have
enjoy it the most but also the people
that are the majority of chess players
in the world and
and so i think i think all of us in in
our own way are
are are moving the game forward yeah
contributing in in some way uh but this
just since you already mentioned po
pog champs how was the overall
experience and
did you know most of these guys before
the tournament started or
did they just appear out of nowhere so i
mean
some of them i knew before um so for
example
i i'll this will go back to my twitch
origins but
i've said this before but the origins of
how i really started streaming on twitch
is i streamed a little bit i think in 20
2016 i think it was or maybe it's 2017.
but in 2018
around october i had this uh i played
the tournament in isle of man and i
think it was maybe
the second to last round or maybe i
think i was sending the last round
i was tied for first place and i lost
this very critical game
um to arkady nidich and that basically
cost me a shot at first place in the
tournament
and i was in just sort of not not a
great place mentally after that event
and so
with the world championship match coming
up uh in in november i actually decided
i was gonna stream a little bit
and one thing that really surprised me
besides the obvious
numbers which were very big for the
magnus match against fabiano
is that there were streamers who were
playing chess at that time so
my first introduction to seeing xqc play
chess
was actually during that match in
november of 2018. so
i was i was actually familiar with him
as far back as then and i saw fourson
and reckful also playing
playing chess back then too so i would
say that was the first time that i saw
some of these guys not not all of them
on playing chess and that i kind of felt
that
even though that died down very quickly
that there are there was always some
potential for chess to get big on twitch
based on what i saw
saw there in in november um but in terms
of overall knowing these people
i was familiar with some of them uh so
obviously forrest and xqc i was familiar
with
um i was familiar with nate hill he was
somebody that i'd already been watching
for quite a while because of because of
fortnite which i do watch from time to
time
so i would say probably like five or six
of them i was familiar with the rest i
i i think i'd seen their names but i
didn't didn't know them
know them personally but it was just it
was really amazing to see and i think to
me uh it
the thing that really made its success
there were there were two things first
of all um it was the fact that it was
there was it was really there's no it
was not self-serving in any way either
to myself or
chess.com and what i mean by that is
there are a lot of there
on twitch you have things called
bounties for example where you can play
a game on stream and make money or or
sponsored
but usually the way it's structured is
that you have to have concurrent
viewership
to get x amount of dollars from these
sorts of things um
and and and so because it wasn't
structured like that people just played
the event essentially what happened is
that
they got they got all the content they
made they made prize money but there was
nothing
that came back to me or to chess.com
and i think that's very unique uh
because it's not it's not common
with all the with a lot of these things
on twitch where you just do something
there they're no requirements the the
the creators
the content creators they're the ones
who get all of the benefit out of it um
uh in general terms so so i think that
was
that was one of the things that made it
really really successful
uh is that they they got to do that and
then secondarily um
it's the fact that all these all almost
all the people who played in pogchamps
they
they had a good time they they did not
get embarrassed in any way there were
many players who were very new to the
games at the start of the term
they took lessons they they studied they
did puzzles they did all these different
things
on stream and off stream and and so the
fact that everybody
almost everybody i mean there were two
people who didn't win any games but the
fact that almost everybody
won a game in the event and had a
positive moment um i think really
reinforced that
that it was just a good event where
everybody had fun and there were no
losers it wasn't competitive
it was just an event that really
broadened broadened chess and
and um and the streamers they they all
loved it i mean probably half the
streamers i would say
privately sent me messages saying thanks
the event was was amazing i really
enjoyed it i hope there's another one
so uh it really it really came out very
well and and i
i mean i personally for me it was it was
just it was amazing because as someone
who's
been in the chess world for most of my
life i mean and i i don't mean this to
be
negative about chess but i feel like a
lot of events
have had potential over the years and
because of one
certain little things that happen the
event either the event doesn't come off
the way you want or it just ends up
turning into a complete failure and so
to see an event like this which was
essentially um
the child of twitch chat basically the
people who are in my twitch chat
suggesting it and then to see the event
come off the way it did uh it was just
it was phenomenal and um i think you
know down the road there will be another
one so
uh it exceeded all my expectations and i
i think um it was just
nothing but pause positive for the chats
community yeah
and i i remember seeing some few years
back
i seen voibor play chess in between his
league of legends games i've seen hutch
play chess
and it was uh well it was interesting to
see that the two of them
have met in in the finals and it was a
well it was really a wild clash
in the end yeah losing i mean i think
that's
no i mean i think sorry what i was gonna
say is i think
um that to me really you could tell with
these guys that they were they were
really really
grateful not not just for the tournament
and i'm referring to hutch and voyboy
specifically
but that basically it gave them a chance
to um to come back and play a game that
they really loved when they were younger
um
like with hutch i think on the broadcast
even he mentioned that got chess got him
through a lot of rough times and
again this is kind of the the point that
i always
um i will always say this about chess is
that for 99
more probably than 99 but for more than
99 of people
it's not about the competitive aspect
it's not about becoming world
becoming a grand master becoming world
champion that's not really ever going to
be the goal
but it's one of those things that can
help you in so many other ways whether
it's getting
you through a tough spot in life whether
it's as a kid coming from a rough
background and
helping you slow down and think um you
know or help you with just like reading
and writing skills critical thinking
skills
the benefits of chess that's really what
i think at the end of the day is most
important so for me
uh when i heard hutch saying how it got
through tough times or void boys saying
how it really
it helped him when he first started
playing i think it was in lcs
um and just like thinking of using chess
to think about
certain things uh in league like it
shows just what what a broad reach chess
has and i i think
um i i was just i thought it was great
especially for hutch someone who i think
many many years ago probably five or six
years ago
uh was playing chess on on twitch um
just to have that opportunity to
to compete many years later was
something that he i think had kind of
kind of forgotten about it was just it
was amazing to see and i i think
i mean i'm really happy that that hutch
and all these other people
had the experience they did yeah and
it's uh i mean it's definitely a win if
uh well if just one of those uh
streamers who were involved in the
tournament or or any of their viewers
you know fire up a game or two now and
then
uh it's definitely definitely a win for
chess
right you know i was thinking i was
thinking also like it's completely crazy
but a few people in my chat
said this and um it's completely insane
but
there is a chance you know you could
have the next world champion you could
have someone who's gonna become one of
the top chess players in the world
watching one of these streams i mean
it's insane to think about it but you
could have someone who's like six seven
eight years old watching
watching whether it's my stream whether
it's xqc or any number of these
streamers
literally you can have a kid watching
the stream and because of these streams
because of these tournaments
they could take they could end up
becoming one of the best chess players
in the world and to me
like the thought is completely crazy but
i think it's it's very
it's definitely valid and um and it's
it's just all around i think it's it's
been great
yeah one day when they will be maybe
somewhere giving an interview they will
say okay i started my
my journey watching someone uh on
pogchamps for example play
in the quarterfinals that's that's the
first thing i remember from chess
could be right right and uh do you yeah
uh dude were you familiar with
charlie before he did the chess drama
video
no i actually was not um so i think
charlie's very big on youtube
i'm a little bit less familiar with
youtube pretty much
um of course there's a limited limited
amount of time in the day
but i'm primari i primarily when i do
watch other
other content it's almost always on
twitch so
um i was not actually familiar with
charlie before that but certainly the
video he did on that
um i think was it was very well done and
it it certainly like i mean i i don't
know if you have a
do you have a question about this
specifically or not well yeah i do but
but feel free to yeah so so yeah i mean
i think i thought the video was great
doing well i wasn't familiar with
charlie i think he did
uh he did bring bring it a lot of
exposure a lot of notice
yeah no that that's what i thought did
you uh how did he get
uh to know about this i mean okay
there's always drama in chess but for
someone he
and yeah he is big on youtube he's like
over 5 million subscribers
and uh he really covers
a lot of internet drama and although
chess is a lot of drama i i didn't
really
get how how this came all the way to him
so i thought maybe
maybe you knew him prior to that so
that's why he did it
no i mean i think really what happened
is and i'm not really sure what what
kind of spark i mean i i know what
sparked initially like the the interest
in chess on twitch
it was definitely the collaborations
that i did with xqc combined with the
fact that xcc started
just playing it uh playing it on a
stream during breaks or when he was
downloading games and so forth so that's
the start but i think really
what happened is at some point everybody
took notice of it and with all the
streamers
um taking notice when when magnus made
this
tweet i think it sort of spilled over
into twitter onto reddit
and um and i think a lot of people just
just by virtue of chess becoming bigger
uh heard about it one way or the other
[Music]
uh you mean to tweet about uh rebranding
well i mean yeah yes there's this tweet
and there's also the final tweet there
they're two
they're they're two sep or not tweet but
the the clips uh i mean they're two
separate things but yes i think
basically
uh because chess was already very
popular um when you started having this
drama it's just everybody was already
hearing about justin was already
becoming very big and and so
uh i think it's just the reach everyone
just started hearing about and seeing it
and just you couldn't really avoid it
okay any of the platforms uh okay but
now since you already mentioned the the
the tweet that magnus tweeted uh what
was what was basically the problem
behind it the way i understood it was
uh they were worried about uh random
viewers uh
checking out your channel and thinking
that the tournament was organized
by chess.com was that the issue um
i'm trying to think of the right way to
put this uh the the simple simple answer
to the question is that magnus was
uninformed about
my discussions with chess 24 prior to
the event his
tweet was uh was a misinformed tweet he
did not realize that i had
conversations with with chess 24 prior
to the event
and i mean i don't know if chess 24
might have had a different stance at the
time if they'd known that it would be so
big but i don't think they
i don't think they were paying attention
to twitch or to my viewership
and so um and so because of that
like sort of magnus you know i think he
saw that i had 20 000 people watching
and he's like what's going on like this
i mean this is this is just wrong
but they had agreed to it they did say
it was completely fine
um prior to the event and uh
and and so it was just magnus was
misinformed so that's basically it
it's only about the views it's not about
uh thinking that
like someone will think that maybe
chess.com organized the event
no no okay so i thought maybe it was
also about that
okay well as i mean magnus magnus made
the tweet to be
to be clear it's magnus and not just 24
but magnus's tweet
was based on it based on
misunderstanding okay
yeah i did i did not know that uh and
also something very interesting uh young
gustavsson asked
alireza once uh on the stream he he
asked him who's the best bullet player
in the world is it magnus or you alireza
and he said it's hikaru
do you agree with this so i think that's
a very interesting question i think
that and the my answer to the question
actually depends on what the website is
specifically
so i would say that um one
what i am probably the best at is i'm
very good at the reaction and
anticipation of my opponent's moves
um so for me when i get this big time
advantage uh i generally
i'm very good at converting when i when
i have more time um so on a site like
chess.com where your time runs
regardless
uh i would say that i probably am the
best under those conditions
but when you go to a site like lead
chess for example being the specific one
um uh you can actually make pre-moves
where you lose no time so you lose point
zero zero zero zero um
for pre moves and i i think one thing
that ali reza especially
is significantly better at than i am is
making very fast free moves
so i don't i i think that's very it
depends on which site you play on and
then
then then to further add like if you
look at chess 24 for example
um you cannot make a pre-move which
doesn't
which doesn't take more than like 1.17
milliseconds
so i think on every site it varies
widely but i think if you play under the
general general thing that you can make
a move in point zero zero one
uh milliseconds on trust.com i think i i
probably
am the best but it varies widely based
based on site
i would say however i do think um i
would
i would consider ali reza to be a better
bullet player than magnus though i i do
consider ali reza to be
better and is it the is it a huge
difference
uh for example when you play one plus
zero then when you play one plus one
yeah it's a he it's a huge difference um
i
i would say the biggest difference
between one plus zero and one plus one
is that one plus one basically just
becomes
uh it becomes like i mean i i actually
i was gonna say i wonder how grishchuck
would do it one plus one because oneplus
one feels like a
game that would that would be made for
him actually where he could get down to
10 seconds
yeah get down to 10 seconds every game
and just like make make every move in
one second
um uh yeah but oneplus one is much
different because you can't really flag
anybody
and and so um when you play one plus one
you have to still find a lot of good
moves as well
of course they're gonna be blunders but
in one plus one it's it's a whole
different game and i i don't even know
who i would say is best i have a feeling
it's probably
i don't think it's probably me i don't
think it's magnus i have a feeling it's
it's probably someone completely
different if you add the time
okay and do you have a
is it the different for you to handle
let's say tournament pressure if you do
experience such a thing
over the board than in online chess like
not so long ago you
played a match against magnus you lost
the first match three to zero but then
you bounced back and then you
you won the third one so how do you like
come back from from a 3-0
yeah so i what i would say is first of
all playing online it's
it's very interesting i i think in many
ways it's actually
more pressure than playing over the
board i think the reason i would say
that is because
uh when you play over the board you're
very aware that there are people
watching you
so like you're very restrained you're
very very sort of controlled per se
whereas when you're
sitting at home in front of your
computer it's very easy to forget that
and just like you kind of like lose your
mind like i mean i've done it a few
times magnus has done it i think
everybody's
everybody kind of has shown a lot of
expressions um so i think in a way
it's much harder because it's like you
you you uh you want to be like
more natural but then you realize like
there are always
all these people watching so i think
that actually adds a lot of pressure
psychologically
um uh for online as opposed to over the
board now in terms of um
in terms of like coming back from being
behind like three three zero
i think the main thing is with that
format you realize it's only one match
and
i think what a lot of people and this is
something that makes chess hard to
relate to but what a lot of people i
think don't understand
is that when you're behind in matches
like and you're in situations which are
must win or you know like even if it's
only a draw like whatever it is the
result
your desired result when you only have
one result um you're going to take risks
you're going to do things that are
that are not natural and and so like
when people say three nothings like oh
wow like that's just terrible it's the
end of the world but
uh i mean i could have played something
solid instead and drawn the game
probably but i still would have lost
match so it didn't
the score didn't really affect me if
anything i thought the fact that i lost
three nothing was a good sign because
you want to get all the bad games out of
your system
in that one match that you have a chance
in the other two to play better
um and then coming back i think really
was just um
i mean it was it was actually i think
very similar to the final which i lost
to do bob where
in day two the first game magnus kind of
um
he got a great position maybe even
winning and um and then he sort of fell
asleep yeah
i won that game uh with with white and
and it's the same thing like basically
in the first game against dubob
um on on the second second day i
basically fell asleep at the wheel and
this in this uh in this alpine sicilian
and just started drifting in the middle
game and then and then of course
he converted quite nicely and so i think
in both those matches
the second day was really critical when
when i was behind then also when duval
was behind where
uh you just you you get that good start
to the second day instead of feeling
like you're
you're on edge because once you win that
first game it gives you a lot of
confidence and so
um i think that's the big thing in terms
of why i came back was the second day
start off really well and the third day
um i mean i just try i just try to play
good moves and i think
i think for magnus um he seems to be a
little bit
a little bit uh i would say a little bit
more nervous perhaps online he does he
seems more tentative i would say than he
does over the board and
i think that that played a big role um
so
yeah okay so you're saying you're more
nervous playing online
i think i think you just don't know what
to expect it's
like you you really don't know because
like yeah
it's i don't i don't even know how to
explain it but you just you feel like
it's it's all much more unpredictable
somehow it's like you just don't really
don't know what to expect
even though i mean of course it's the
same game but i mean
but it's online so for me i mean i do i
know if i feel more nervous but i feel
like much more uncertain about what's
going to happen when i play online than
than over the board and also because you
can have things like mouse slips as well
you know or disconnections which which
can occur too
so i think that that certainly doesn't
help either yeah
it's like you you have less less control
but also something i wanted to ask you i
think was maybe some five years ago or
something like that
there was this uh article on chess.com
uh and uh they asked a bunch of people
you amongst them
like who do you who do you consider the
top five most influential
world champions and like uh pretty much
everyone had
bobby fischer either in the first place
or maybe in the in the top three but you
do not consider him like in the top five
at all so i
i always uh thought that was really uh
well really weird so is there like uh is
do you just consider other world
championships
was that was that as a player or was
that someone like who who pushed the
game forward
who mostly influenced the game okay okay
yeah i mean i think with fisher
um he had an influence but it was very
temporary and and this this i think is
also if if i go
this sort of gets back to one of the
earlier things i said is that chess has
had booms before
it's it's had booms and busts um and
for the most part they always seem to
die out i felt that that boom in in 1972
uh could have been much more sustained
it could have lasted a lot longer if
bobby fischer had stayed in the game or
he'd stayed relevant
um instead of instead of you know
refusing to play play against karpov a
couple years later
so i think that's the main reason that i
don't don't consider him one of the most
influential because it was so short and
so brief
and in many ways i think i think what
happened is when he left the game
it reinforced certain stereotypes very
negative stereotypes um
about the game of chess and the people
who do play chess so
he was influential but i i don't
necessarily consider it to be through
his own
his own doing i think it's through his
results and through the through through
on
the time period that we're in but um but
as a player obviously it's completely
different so
in terms and it depends how you how you
yeah
okay that that makes sense but i'm kind
of curious do you actually do you
have the list of the five people that i
said yeah i do
okay i want to see if i can say i'm one
i wonder if i'll say the same five or no
okay actually um so obviously kasparov
obviously anond um i would say magnus
carlsen
um it's probably those those are three
uh
this person i definitely did not say but
i think because of his contributions as
an or
as uh as president of pda i would say
max oyva as
well um and then that's for
and who did fifth one be um
yeah let's see who the fifth one be
yeah i i i would probably say kappa
blanc is what i would say because i just
have to go back in time to come up with
come up with a fifth one i don't really
have a strong preference but
i know those are not the five that i
said because i know i did not say max
but
you you did get two correct only two
okay only two yeah yes you mentioned
mikhail botwinic
gary kasparov uh jose royal capoblanca
alexander rajen
and anatoly karpov okay those were
your five in those days but yeah i
figured that maybe
it did kind of change now yeah i mean i
i think probably a large part of why
that changed uh
actually like yeah i think bob vinnick
bob finnegan probably should have said
said in this list just because he
established the whole system um
the russian system uh the russian method
for for learning chess and obviously was
very very successful
many people came out of that school um
but so like when i look at someone like
max oyva i think certainly
that's somebody who made a very big
contribution as the president of fiji
and
and so it's it's different than like
what i would what i said back thanks
think about those names like aliakin or
bob binnick i mean these are guys like
the influence i think of as as a chess
player like the this
you know ali atkins uh refining the
openings or bob bennett creating the
whole system
um so it's directly related to playing
the game of chess whereas like
with max oyva it's it's more like just
pushing the game forward
um being president of feeding and and so
i mean i kind of think maybe a large
part of why i would say a name like that
now is because
for me as i'm trying to do things to to
to raise the profile of chess it's sort
of in that same vein it's not
something directly related to playing
the game of chess it's trying to
it's trying to make it more accessible
for people so i so i think that probably
what's happened
has shifted my view a little bit okay
and do you do you have any other plans
uh
for your streams other than chess like
you mentioned you
you uh watch some fortnight you watch
somewhere i i've seen you watch other
streamers
for sometimes play something else but
i've never seen you actually play
something
so i've actually played valor in the
last couple of days on myself
um what i would say in general is that i
don't think i'll ever do a stream that
is is
uh is doesn't have any chess in it
because i mean at the end of the
end of the day chess is what i am most
known for it's what i'm going to be the
best i
i mean it really doesn't matter what
other game i play i'll never be as good
at anything else in this lifetime as i
am
just so i don't think i'll ever do
streams without any chess but one of the
things
right now that's very unique is that
there are a lot of online chess terms
like there's still this magnus event
there's another one after and there's a
grand final in august as well
um so with all these events going on
it's one of those things where i do want
to branch out a little bit more
but it's going to be down the road
simply because if let's just say you
know let's say i boot up my stream an
hour from now and i uh
and i i play like 10 hours of of some
some game fortnight valor and
you know uh whatever game it is um
there is i do open myself up to a
certain amount of criticism if i don't
perform in these events and i am very
mindful of that
so i won't be doing it in the near
future i would say in the next month or
two but down the road i probably will
play
play other games um specifically i mean
i will i will play valor
some i will probably play uh team fight
tactics the league of legends game
um those are probably the two games most
likely that i'll play on stream
uh that i could play for hours but but
mainly i think i'll continue to do what
i'm doing but with a mix of them i don't
think i'll ever devote streams
solely to playing playing other games
have you ever tried like playing
a game and chess simultaneously like
maybe a
team fight tactics plus chess like a
bullet on the other screen maybe
yeah so you so it's like it's that's the
same concept as when i see uh
like void boy or yasuo right when
they're queuing up they're queueing up
uh in league
and they play play a game of chess at
the same time oh no they they only do it
while queuing up but you could like play
both simultaneously
yeah i mean i i guess i could because in
teamfight tactics yeah
you do you do normally have like 30
seconds to set it up um
yeah i mean maybe maybe i would consider
doing it i i haven't i haven't really
thought about bought it out in that kind
of a way but
um but i will say that uh with all the
chess that i have done
um i do sometimes want a little bit of a
break so i i will do other games on
stream
probably i will always do some chess but
i i will definitely have periods where i
do other games as well yeah sometimes
i tried uh i tried like playing a three
minute blitz game on one screen and
let's say a game of hearthstone
battlegrounds and the other one and it
seems like you have so much time but
for like for me you don't like um oh i'm
constantly late here and i'm constantly
late here
so it'd be it'd be interesting to see
like you who are so much faster would
you be able to like tackle but
tackle both of them yeah i mean i i
think it would be the only thing i would
say about this i think would be very
hard because one of the things that i i
will say
um and i think in many ways this makes
me a little bit more unique is that
i can actually play good chess while
reading chat and having like a gazillion
thoughts going through my mind at the
same time
um so trying to play two games and
rechat and have all these thoughts
at the same time i don't know i mean i
think my brain might explode honestly
but
but i i might try it down there yeah
something something to consider
yeah yeah okay so that pretty much
covers our topics on on
online stuff uh and something uh that i
wanted to ask you i
i kind of remember like maybe reading
about it a few years back
that you are married yes no i'm not
married
you're not married no no i'm single were
you ever married
no i was not ever married really i i
totally remember like reading that uh
you were married no nope uh okay okay
okay
that uh that that's really weird it's
like the
the mandela effect or something
uh but okay then uh if uh if that's a
no-go
uh what i really wanted to know is how
how did they approach you
uh for the for the uh billions uh
uh for the show where you appeared
so so yeah as far as billions is
concerned um the way that came about was
uh i think
the the show producers of billions since
it's a show that's based in new york
they actually reached out to someone
that i know at the marshall chess club
um in new york city about getting a
grand master to appear on the show
and um and so so they they went and
approached uh the people at the chess
club and then they started sending out a
couple of emails
and it was through that that my
stepfather received an email uh from i
think it was the president
at the martial chess club asking about
it and then through that we connected
directly with
uh with with the uh with the producers
of billions
um and then and then yeah and then i
just went to upstate new york
and uh shot it all in day it was like
six hours um there's a lot of fun i
enjoyed i had a chance to hang out and
talk to a couple of the cast members and
and really seeing the whole process that
goes into making a show like that it's
really
i mean everybody thinks of show business
being super glamorous but i think all
the cast members literally every morning
they're
you know they get chauffeured so they
don't have to drive at least but they're
it's an it's an hour drive to like
upstate new york and they have to do
that every morning like 6 a.m
do do the shooting until probably like 9
or 10 in the evening when it wraps up
and
and so it's just a lot of long days and
a lot of hard work and i think seeing
that
um i was just amazed by by all these
people they do it every single day and
even even the people behind the scenes
who are
who are doing the filming and the the
show runners like everybody it's just
it's amazing to
see the process at work and i i really
did enjoy it it's a lot of fun
in the scene where you just go uh oh i
think your line is like a
checkmate good game uh is it uh did you
were you able to do it on the first try
so this is kind of what's amazing um is
that
when i say six hours i mean literally
like we filmed it from different angles
angles different scene setups four or
six hours so
um basically i think at the start uh
there was the idea there would be eight
tables there would be like
two two or maybe it was like three two
three or something but i make a move on
one side go to the other side come
around to
the side where um where where where
where uh mike burbigle is the
the actor um and and i do it sort of in
a sequence so we did a couple of those
sorts of takes
and then later on then we took some of
those tables out then we had uh we had
like a
a spot where like a trolley was coming
down down the middle of the middle of
the pathway um but
it was not one take and i actually
thought it would be something relatively
relatively brief like maybe take like
one hour but they did they did film
all all the angles a lot of different
takes and
and i'm not even sure the final take
they ended up using i think was actually
one of the takes from later on
in fact um of the shooting so so like i
said
it was not just like i wasn't like i'm
in there do this in like 15 minutes and
go home
they they were very thorough they they
filmed it from all different angles
there were scenes where i was in it for
the dialogue
scenes where i was not in it at all with
the dialogue so it's just um
they they did a lot a lot of a lot of
work on it and it wasn't something um
and and and it wasn't something that
just took five minutes
okay so your part that you did was six
hours
and the suit you had was it also theirs
is it or is it yours no no
that that was mine uh i don't know yeah
i think if you're a main cast member
they they sort of they do have a
wardrobe department but if you aren't
then i think it's just uh if you're just
like a
guest you know if you're just a guest uh
making camera or something
they they didn't so i just brought my
own suit but and did you get some makeup
maybe they did your hair or was it all
you
yeah yeah they did a little bit of
makeup yeah but before we did the
filming they
i went to the the makeup makeup studio
um and and yeah i was
but the whole thing really just was was
exceptional and uh
like i said before there's a lot that
goes into it that i think people don't
realize it's not
it's not some simple process so so yeah
i was just it was a great experience and
i mean i
i i i'd love to do more of that yeah
it's
possible that uh that there will be uh
like opportunities for more like uh
every
other like tv show on netflix i see has
chess in it like uh the the money heist
constantly has chess in it the blacklist
constantly like there are there's
literally chess
in every episode so it's uh also you
know
maybe maybe knocking on the big doors
yeah i mean i think this is also one of
the reasons like i've always tried to
try to figure out like what
what is going on with chess in terms of
why is it why are there not more
sponsors why is it not popular because
it's very true if you
in a lot of tv shows you will see chess
in it for whatever i mean no matter how
short it is you will see
you will see chess and so many of these
different tv shows and and even like
on television in ads you almost all like
i've seen i don't even know how many
insurance ads i've seen where it's like
there's somebody in a park playing chess
in the 30-second ad
so yeah um chess seems to be everywhere
and that to me that's always been the
kind of
questions why is it why is it so popular
in a way but why is it like
not prominent like you see it in all
these ads you see it you see it
everywhere
almost everybody's heard of the game of
trust but then like it doesn't have any
traction
um in terms of something that people are
interested so
um i in many ways i feel like uh
what's happened especially on twitch and
just the general boom
it sort of validates what i've always
believed which is that there are a lot
of people who do like chess
but it's a matter of finding like sort
of the way to bring it to people
um and that's always i think been been
the issue
yeah okay and uh one other thing i'm
interested in
uh i've seen you tweet about it
sometimes and
maybe maybe you are into it maybe you're
not uh do do you do trading
i have in the past i mean lately i have
not been doing it just because i've been
so busy with that which probably
i mean this is this is sort of a very
very sort of negative take i would say
but
but
but i i always have kind of i've always
been interested in it but i feel like
what i've seen
um probably in like the last couple of
years honestly to me it feels like the
whole system is rigged
and i don't say that in a way like i'm
not doing well because i'm doing
completely fine
but it feels very rigged in that it
feels like the forces that be
are kind of manipulating and forcing the
market to go a certain direction
um and so i've kind of lost i would say
at least in the last couple of months
i've
lost a lot of interest because of what
i've seen with the real world problems
that people are struggling with and then
having say the federal reserve
which more or less is intentionally
keeping the stock market
inflated to help people who are who are
very wealthy so
uh just when i see stuff like that it's
it's not that i i won't get back into it
at some point but
it makes me very pessimistic and very
negative because it feels very wrong
that you have
you have people out there who are losing
their jobs people are struggling every
single day
and then you then you have you have
obviously the stock market being bailed
out and
artificially um propped up so that
people who are rich um are okay so so i
mean
it's not that i won't get back into it
but what i've seen especially in the
last couple of months makes me
i don't know it makes me very very
negative and pessimistic and i feel like
it's just like it's it's i don't know it
just bothers me
yeah i'm asking because i've never i've
never tried it myself and it always uh
seemed like so something like uh like an
illusion to me like how do you even
how do you even start that is it is it
sort of something you could maybe study
and get good at or is it
like gambling or i mean i think there
are many many things there's certain
parts that definitely are
like i mean i would say it's certain
parts like derivatives that are very
it's very much like um it's very much
like uh
like poker for example where it's it's a
lot of like you try to make informed
decisions but if you're wrong you're
just wrong
um okay but but the general thing i
would say also is
um is that there are always going to be
opportunities uh for individual
investors
where when the market collapses you can
you can do very well and you can buy
these bargains for example what happened
in march when
when everything started shutting down
you saw most of the
most of the uh most of the the markets
go down by at least like 25 to 30
percent if not more and there were a lot
of bargains there where you could buy
just for example stock like amazon at
say 1500
and now it's something near 2700 so
it's just a huge return um but in
general i think
uh it's not something that people should
expect to get rich from
unless you're already very wealthy you
have a lot of money to play with but
i i think it's some it's a good thing to
to learn how to invest at least on a
basic level because you will over the
long run if you just invest in
and say index funds you will you will
make money but
in terms of trading i think it takes a
very specific mindset it also takes
a lot of work and being on top of
everything and i i can say from personal
experience
um it's it's it's it's impossible to
to really make money from it if you're
not completely focused on it
um and like for example uh
what i mean by that is i i don't
remember which tournament was during but
there was one term that i was playing
um and i think at the time i was in i
think i was in maybe it was netflix
stock or something but literally
i i needed to be watching it right on
the open at 9 30 eastern
in order to close the position but
because i because i was playing a game
or doing other things
um and i only saw it a couple hours
later um i end up losing money on that
trade because the stock from being up
like five percent ended up down two
percent or whatever it was
and so it's one of those things that i
think uh if you if you really want to be
super serious about it takes an insane
amount of work and
and effort and it's something that
probably isn't isn't worthwhile i
i always enjoy enjoy doing it on a small
scale but
um i think the main thing that to take
from it is learning about investing
learning how
long term you will make money so i think
a lot of chess players um
tend not to not to think about things
like that and think about long term
um in the in the right right sort of
ways and
and and like for me one of the biggest
things i've always thought is like
you you always assume you're gonna be
playing chess like for me i've always
thought i'll be playing chess forever um
but you really never know when the end
is going to come for example even now
there's there's no guarantee that i will
ever improve my classical ranking again
this could be the end for me
um in a way potentially uh yeah i
i mean i know it sounds silly uh
obviously but i mean there's no saying
that like i
when if chess comes back that i won't
have bad results my rate ranking won't
fall out of top 25
and i won't get invitations that is a
very real possibility it's a very real
thing that i do have to be concerned
about and so
um you know when i think about things
like that in the in the
the grander scheme of things uh you
always want to make sure you have some
backups or some things to fall back on
um and so that that i think is probably
the main reason is just
to understand that you want to have
other ways to potentially make money
down the road
you know if and when your your chess
career ends so that's the way i got into
it but
i would say in general learning how
learning how to invest you can learn
that from from reading and that
that's i think much more much more um
reasonable than trying to trying to
trying to trade because trading requires
uh
a lot of time a lot of effort things can
go wrong you have to be very strong
mentally as well
and um it's not something you can just
learn either
what's that and you're obviously not
allowed to sleep
well i mean if you only trade the us
markets you can but
but in general yes it's one of those
things that i think it's uh
it's very very difficult and it's
something that requires a very
kind of hardened mentality in order to
be successful and so i think i think for
most people just just learning the basic
rules of investing
um rather than keeping money in cash i
would say um
matters matters it matters a lot in in
long run
but it's just something i've always
always been interested in from from
a young age okay on a more cheerful note
i've noticed on your instagram account
you've uh
went to hawaii to hana pepe and you've
jumped out of an airplane
how was that uh one of the best
experiences of my life honestly um so
so this is the other thing that that in
a way i think is very good
is um i i was very fortunate i decided
to actually take a vacation
early march and go to hawaii and
literally i would say two days after i
came i think it was two or three days
after i came back from hawaii to florida
is when the lockdown started it started
occurring in the us
um uh pretty much across the board so so
um i went in early march and uh there
were many things i did a lot of hiking
as well
i i did skydiving but i i would say
skydiving probably was one of
one of one of my favorite favorite
activities i've done
and um i have thought about it been down
the road potentially if uh
if things get back normal i might i
might actually try to go and uh
get the uh get i don't know what they
call the license or what what they call
but where you can actually just jump so
i think you do something like
uh eight or nine jumps um you have to do
it with an instructor and
and everything but down the road uh i
might try and actually
go and do the jumps and and and learn
the proper techniques and so i can
so i can do it solo in the future um but
it was a great experience i
i loved it i think uh i think it's one
of those things that
everybody should do at least once
because it's just like letting go
of all your worries and all your fears
and kind of just just uh
just just letting just just living free
basically
and how long is the leap does it feel
like it lasts forever or is it like
super quick
um so i think it's about i think it
varies depending on
on the height you jump from but i i
think for me it was probably
maybe like 45 seconds to a minute i
think before they pulled the chute um
but yeah i think it's just it's one of
those experiences just just completely
letting go
uh and i think in many ways like not to
use the
not to use the the matrix quote so it
sounds really cheesy but it's like it's
freeing your mind basically
when you do something like that you have
no control like you're basically you're
in the air you're you're of course you
know
coming back down to earth but you have
literally no control and
and i think i think it's one of those
things it's not the only thing you can
do like that obviously
but it's one of one of those things
where when you do it i think it really
makes you realize
um just like you know kind of just how
to have fun just like
you can't you can't always be worrying
about every last little thing that's
going on in your life and
and so i i loved it it's one of the it's
one of those things that i
i was when you get up there first before
you jump you're like it's like oh man
you're looking down
because because basically you go up in a
small small airplane and they just open
open the open sidewinder you jump out
just like oh man like you look like
you're so high you're just going to
jump to your death but uh then then once
you actually cross that across that that
line you just jumped it's uh
just exhilarating i i really enjoy it i
i do plan on doing it again in the
future
how long did it take you to go from
sitting in the airplane to actually
jumping
like so i would say it probably took um
i'm guessing about 10 minutes to get to
get to the altitude i think it was
um i don't know how high it was maybe it
was like five six
thousand feet i think it was maybe a
little bit higher than that but it took
about 10 minutes i think the main thing
is like
i'm i i in general i don't i'm not
afraid of things for the most part
so um like for people who are afraid i
think the main thing with doing it kind
of is you just you don't look out you
just
you try to keep your mind focused on
something anything else uh
before you jump it took about 10 minutes
from from takeoff to get there and then
i would say it took about
five to six minutes i think maybe a
little bit less i don't i don't remember
exactly how long it took but
um but it took took a couple of minutes
to get down but certainly when you jump
out i mean that's just it's it's a great
feeling
and then even when you're drifting
drifting back down after the shoot is
out um
it's just one of those experiences that
i think i mean
pretty much anyone should have okay
thank you for that
and i would like to i would like to end
it with a couple of questions from my
subscribers
they would be very angry if i didn't ask
uh so
are you a fan of any particular tv shows
um okay so i i guess let me think in
terms of
past tv shows there are a lot of shows
that i really like probably my favorites
are um
breaking breaking bad and the wire those
are probably my two favorite shows of
all time pretty much
um those are past shows in terms of
current shows
um i was i haven't i didn't really like
the last
probably season of black mirror but i
really like black mirror and
and lately i actually binged it this
past the past like two weeks a friend
told me about it
what's the show dark on on netflix uh
it's really
the german like the german show yeah
yeah yeah big fan of that show and i
think season three is coming out in
three days so really looking forward to
that
yeah i i agree about the black mirror as
soon as the next netflix acquired it it
just
uh went bad yeah yeah it was
unfortunate but but still even that like
i've watched some of those episodes and
it it does make you wonder what what the
future is going to look like because
some episodes are really silly
but there are some episodes where you
see things you're like wait that's
already happening yeah yeah like uh if
someone gets a lot of likes and
uh a lot of comments online it means
that he's telling the truth or that
right he's innocent or something like
that yeah we could be very close to that
all right so uh a few more from the
subscribers
uh what was your favorite chess opening
growing up
um favorite house opening probably um
with black it was it was always the
sicilian night or and then with white i
loved playing with the scotch opening
those were my two favorites
uh okay uh and
what is the favorite game that you
played yourself
favorite game that i played i think it's
probably the game against boris gelfand
um at the world team championship in in
versa in 2010
um primarily because it was an idea that
i've been familiar with for a long time
but going into that game i also had a
really i think i had a really bad score
against boris
i'm not even sure if i had any wins
against him in in classical chess
and kind to play that game and win the
way i did as quickly as i did
um it was just it almost was was just a
shock at the time
um and then obviously just to use that
night the night the bishop and the pawn
that the common theme of the checkmate
combined with that queen d3
um it's definitely my favorite game
by quite a big margin when you offered
your queen like four times
right right well yeah because it was
always a checkmate on g yeah always
always some some form of that checkmate
so that that definitely was
is my favorite game yeah i i agree with
that that that's my favorite game you
played as well
uh and what's uh the favorite game that
you've lost
if there is such a thing favorite game
that i've lost um
okay so i have to think about miniatures
um
hmm let me think if there's a if there's
a favorite game that i've lost
actually i would probably say it's a
game um
i'm sure there are others but i would
say right off it's a game that i lost to
uh fabiano in london i think it was
probably three years ago was in the
sicilian idol when he played this bishop
g5 variation he sacked his queen for two
pieces um
that i think it was 2017 might have been
2018 but that would be my favorite uh
that would be my favorite game uh that i
lost at least right now
okay uh it doesn't really build but but
i will check it out
uh okay here's a interesting one uh
someone asked
what's with the head tilting
oh the head tilting i think that's just
uh that's just a natural thing that i've
picked up
um over the years i think it's just one
of those uh
one of those behaviors you know one of
those mannerisms that i have
um i i think i i don't know how how most
shots players do this but i i've noticed
all childish players in some form when
they're when they are thinking
about something uh on the chessboard
they they usually look away now
i tend to tilt my head and look up
towards the sky i think chooky does this
a lot as well by the way um but some
people just like they stare like
side to side i think it's just everyone
whatever it is
that whatever mannerism they have it
makes them do that just that's their way
of doing the calculation in their head
um but i don't there's no specific
reason it's just one of those things i
think i picked up at a young age
and um and it's just a trait that i have
but but all chess players i think at
least the elite chess players
they do something similar some form of
it um
maybe not fabiano maybe not fabiano
actually but he's the only one that i
can think of who i i don't think
necessarily does it but i think almost
everybody else does yeah but
he goes all the way like he he just goes
all the way up there right right okay
someone asked what's the best way to
improve middle game
i think the best way to improve middle
games is um
is just to look at the games the top
players are playing
from a set position on movetown let's
say it's the italian opening just look
at the set position that they get to on
move 10 in a game between like myself
and chris shucker
or magnus and vichy whomever it is but
just look at the top games
and try to see what the ideas are uh in
that middle game when you get the set
position
rather than like trying to plan it out
because i think one thing that people
try to do too much is they try to plan
out the whole game
from start to finish and unless you're
extremely lucky that's that's never
gonna happen
um so i think it's mainly just look at
the top players games in the openings
that you're familiar with
on like move 10. don't look at like the
specific you know like the
specific line but just get to like move
10 or move 12 whatever it is after both
players have castle
and finish the development and just look
at the ideas that they come with the
moves specifically just go over those
games
okay uh uh have you ever tried using a
cheap trick
against a grand master uh you said cheap
right
yeah yeah like um like an opening trick
or something
hmm so i mean the problem is everybody's
so well prepared now that even if i try
to do that against the master it
wouldn't work in this day and age um
i i don't i'm sure i probably did when i
was much younger but right off the top
my head i can't recall
um trying to do it yeah i can't recall
playing any specific gambits that
were just bad or stuff like that um so
so no yeah
i thought as much all right
uh is there do you have some sort of a
special diet for your brain
uh no i i don't have any diet i mean i
guess what i would say in general is
at least for me kova has been i mean
it's been it's been very bad over well
one of the things that it has done is i
do tend not to eat as much uh
junk food of course most people in
america are very familiar with what junk
food is i think in europe actually it's
a lot less common certainly because
people don't eat out as much
but because of covet i've actually
generally been eating at home so i
i think the main thing is just avoiding
all the all the greasy fast food that
that america has um unfortunately that's
the main thing i've been doing but
i don't have a specific specific diet
per se
okay and someone also asked are you
superstitious
uh you always wear your famous sweater
for for your big games
yeah so i mean that's specific to the
magnus event generally i'm not
um but i just i feel comfortable and
it's worked so i see no reason not to
uh i would say i'm somewhat
superstitious um in terms of like
wearing like a sweater or
like a certain shirt per se but that's
really as far as it extends um i don't
generally take it beyond that
okay i think that's something a lot of
elite players in their sports
share uh someone someone
well a lot of people actually mentioned
this they uh they said that you
you've some somehow changed over the
last few years almost like in character
do you feel that
also about yourself um yeah i mean i
think
okay this is a this is a question that i
can answer much more in depth
um i i guess what i would say in general
terms
is basically my whole character and
persona has shifted over the years
what i would say is when i was very
young um what drove me or what made me
really good
not just at chess but in general being
very competitive was sort of having this
fire
and feeling like you know it was the
world against me so so when i say
like world against man i'm talking when
i was like probably a teenager-ish
uh and and and like this it's it's it's
interesting because like
a lot of people now consider me a
prodigy um but
when i was growing up i certainly did
not feel like the chosen one or feel
like a prodigy or someone who's going to
go on to do great things so
when i was younger a lot it was sort of
i felt like it was me against the world
like i really had to be um
i kind of had to just like maybe not
hate everyone but i had to use sort of
the
the the negativity like the fact that
people weren't fans of me and used to
fuel me to get better and better at the
game
so when i was younger i i mean certainly
i i basically enjoyed the
that mentality of everyone is against me
i'm going to use that as my fuel as the
fire
uh the motivation to get really good at
the game so when i was younger that was
the big thing um
and also i would say since since i
started getting not getting good but
since i was um
since i was already like a grand master
at 15 uh
it's like kind of you you realize
like what it took to get there and then
like actually being there it's
it's not always going to be the same and
so for me once i actually started
once i became a grand master i started
improving it's like well
well it's a little bit different because
now actually people people do respect
you and maybe this
maybe this actually comes back to
elitism a little bit in a way
but but it felt but it seemed different
like there was certainly more respect
towards what i was doing
um and being being a very strong chess
player and so i would say over time that
changed a little bit and then
um and then beyond that i think once
once you keep improving at a certain
point like
you you also you also mature you also
grow up and kind of you realize like
being angry at everyone sort of like
hating the world it's not
it's not um i guess it's not beneficial
is what i found especially as i get
older and and also once you mature you
start realizing like why should you be
angry at everyone like what's the point
what purpose does it serve we're all
gonna
we're all gonna die at some point anyway
um so mainly i think
i think like i really needed that like i
had to have that personality to get to
where i got in chess because without
that
motivation that that sort of that that
that fire
um i don't think i would have ever
gotten as good as i did so that was the
first thing um and then i would say in
the last
couple of years um obviously i've been
competing for a long time
and i think one of the things that's
that you feel is uh
you kind of can't be close you can't you
can't be close to your competitors and
i'll go off topic for one second but one
thing that i've noticed with and this is
specific to magnus actually
is that magnus makes he makes it a habit
of trying to have this mysterious
personality where nobody ever sees him
accepted the board so
for example um i think i think i play
whenever i played this london classic
term in london um
i think the last few years at least when
magnus has been playing there
he literally does not stay at the site
hotel he goes and stays somewhere
completely different
um off-site and everything and um
and so he kind of has developed this
mysterious personality where like no one
sees him so it's like i mean
like like what is he doing who is he you
don't really kind of view him in the
same way as being like
a real person i guess like because he
just you never see him like you know if
i see lavon at breakfast or something
it's like okay this is lavon you know
he's a cool guy he's normal like all the
rest of us
but magnus uh makes makes a specific
habit i think
of trying to uh trying not to be be
visible during
during these events and so um so when i
get back get back
to myself and like i talk about about
personality i would say for for a long
time
um i had that same sort maybe not not
quite the same approach but sort of like
i don't really want to be friendly with
my competitors they are the people i'm
competing against
i do need to beat them at the end of the
day um
but i would say especially in the last
couple of years uh
when when i mean more or less i've i
feel like i've accomplished everything
except becoming world champion
uh it feels more and more like uh
the the end is closer than the beginning
so you start to realize that at some
point
it's not all going to be there and and
you do want to be more friendly you do
want to have more
interactions with these people because i
am on the tail end as opposed to being
being at the front end so i think that
um
is is the main thing i would say over
the last few years i've started to
realize the end is closer than the than
the beginning
and um and it is more important at this
stage
to uh to try and push the game forward
try and do things that are good for the
game
as opposed to just simply focusing a
hundred percent on being like
really really concentrated really
focused and like super super serious and
and sort of um just i don't know
standoffish or just being aloof
okay so shifting the the focus from
yourself to being the ambassador of the
yeah and i mean i i would you know i
think there are examples in many
different many different fields i
i since tennis is the sport that i that
i've uh that i'm most familiar with i've
played it the most and i also follow it
probably the most
um i would use an example from tennis i
would say if you look at somebody like
andre agassi specifically
um he was very much a bad boy when he
was on the scene in the early 90s
very much bad boy the wild hair
obviously the drugs and all the other
stuff um
but then when you saw him come back i
think it was something around like 97
98 when he went from like 140 or
whatever it was in the world back to i
think number one
um you kind of saw that he was a
different person like he had maturity
realized
he obviously wanted to compete and be
the best but the whole persona was
different like it was about
doing good things within tennis and
being sort of the ambassador as one of
the
one of the older people on the tour and
so for me
i kind of view it the same view sort of
like my role in shots in the same way
where it's
it's more like i need to also try to be
one of the ambassadors because most of
the people i play against now are
younger than me which is
i mean it's it's a very weird feeling
when i play when i play a tournament and
you know it's like people like duda or
fabiano like i mean even fabiano who i
feel like
i've known forever i mean he still is
like what like six or seven years
younger than me
um and so when i play his tournaments
and literally the only people who are
older than me are bishi and probably
labon
um you kind of you start to realize your
role and you kind of
i think it's important to to understand
um
what that role is okay very thorough
and uh yeah also a popular question uh
if you could give your younger self some
advice what would it be
um if i could give my younger self some
advice i think honestly it would be um
just try to try to enjoy enjoy the ride
a bit more because i felt like the
period probably
uh from probably 17 maybe not 17 but
probably from like about
the time that i i dropped out of college
probably like 18 19
until i was probably about 24 25 all
those those early years like they just
blur together
um now when i look back on them and and
i i kind of wish i had enjoyed them a
little bit more
um obviously playing serious chess was
great but i wish i had enjoyed some of
those experiences some of those places
and
and some of the people more more than
more than more than i did
yeah it's like that there there's this
song about chess
one night in bangkok that talks about
how chess players view the world and
it's like
every city is the same you see the chess
board is your opponent and
that that's just it okay thank you for
hikaru
and for the end i have a question for
you uh you have to guess uh
which grand master said this uh quote
are you ready all right so the quote is
i am a chess player and not a poet or
philosopher
chancellor not a poet or philosopher
he said grandmaster right yeah yeah a
very strong one
yeah i assumed a strong one i'm not a
poet or philosopher
um i don't know write off so i'm gonna
have to make you guys
okay not a poet or philosopher
it's okay i'm not a poet or a
philosopher
i'm gonna i'm gonna guess that it's
bobby fisher that's my guess but it's
probably wrong
okay that's my guess well uh close
it's it's actually you oh it's me oh
yeah
i dug it up like uh i think it was from
2014 or 2015. uh you started it
yeah you actually started your article
with those words
you said this is my first blog on
chess.com so i'd like to write something
really eloquent and profound
so i can look back on this moment
however i'm a chess player and not a
poet
or a philosopher it's it's it's fun it's
funny actually because
again i think this goes in this sort of
fits with the last question where were
you asking about how like i've changed
over the past couple years like
even a quote like that actually i would
i would actually never i would never say
that now because i'm
obviously not a poet or a philosopher
but i do think that my overarching uh
my philosophy my views on chess do very
they are
they are like my views on chess are very
greatly influenced by
by my philosophy on life and everything
else so i i probably would i would i
would definitely
not write that that quote now okay uh
do you think uh is there anything we we
could have mentioned that we didn't
no i mean i think i think we more or
less cover it all i think just in
general
um i'm very grateful to see to see the
growth that chess has had
um on the internet i mean i think i
think going forward
i do feel that it will be sustained i
don't think it's something that is a fad
or it's going to fade away in a month
but i do think
um at least as far as i'm concerned i
think what you really want though is you
want people to keep on
moving forward keep on keep on doing
these events and keeping keeping the
flame going so i think one of the
biggest issues with chess
is whenever there are these booms that
start usually somewhere in the middle
um whether it's like due to bad
organization or due to people leaving it
feels like it all falls apart
i think i think right now especially
with what's with what's going on across
various shot sites across twitch um i
think chess is here to stay and it's
it's just a very exciting time for for
the game of chess and i'm just grateful
to really be a part of it cause i think
if this happened maybe even a year later
or a year earlier
there's no guarantee that i would have
been in the same spot and so i'm just
grateful for everything
okay hikaru thank you for your time
thank you for joining me i had a had a
wonderful time we had some technical
difficulties but we were able to
overcome them and
yeah for the audience i don't know if
you can see the board
there's actually a position here from
hikaru's game uh
a very famous one so you can try and
guess which one is it and hikaru agreed
to play one blitz game
against me for the end of the podcast so
if you want to check that out the link
will be uh in the description below
so thanks icaru thank you everyone and
we will see you soon
[Music]
you